d'ailleurs vous avez vu moi y'a un truc
aussi qui me chagrine ah je sais pas où
va aller où antoine griezmann ah oui ça
les partis de gauche et alors c'est bon
le beau temps d'abord tout le monde me
demandait ce qui pas barcelone vous ce
qui ma part cela est bon d'en avoir le
coeur net vu hier un sur le dock sur
l'homophobie dans le football et elle
seule qui a parlé il est formidable
c'est pour ça qu'on les aime et c'est
pour ça que c'est si voilà c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime aller je l'appelle
de suite on va voir alors je sais pas si
la mon nouveau numéro
ce que j'ai que trois personnes qui
l'ont voilà que la mersey dont une qu'il
a volé je n'allais jamais donné le
répète les personnes ici clairement du
roi qui je ne n'ai pas donné corps qui a
été le volet à l'année un indice sa
blonde oui elle est de ce côté
une personne qui a été chaparder 0
j'appelle actuellement antoine griezmann
je vais lui laisser un message
et peut-être me rappellera
ultérieurement bien entendu puisqu'il
doit dire qu'est ce que c'est que ce
numéro
qu'est ce que c'est que cette mascarade
what the fuck antoine frérot c'est cyril
hanouna voilà rappelle moi c'était mon
numéro
rappelle moi je suis en émission late
show en direct voilà j'ai appris que tu
quitté l'atlético de madrid
je suis je sais pas je suis entre le
marteau et l'enclume
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas quoi en
penser
est ce que tu viens au psg ça serait
super parce que tu seras côté si tu
viens à marseille c'est pas mal aussi
guingamp j'adore mais ont certainement
des 102 mais bon je pense que si tu
arrives et vont devoir vendre toute la
ville entière
donc voilà donc ça fait déjà cédé en
fait désordre
on me dit que tu vas à barcelone si tu
vas barcelone sache que j'y serai cet
été
donc éventuellement on peut se creuser
éventuellement à barcelone voilà je t'ai
donné toutes les infos tu sais que je
suis là bas et si tu veux que je mette
un petit billet pour ton transfert
oublie mon numéro et merci je t'embrasse
[Applaudissements]